Protesters in Budapest usually start here
at the Hungarian parliament.
This afternoon, I meet a couple of students
preparing for an anti-Orban demonstration.
"Hungary has experienced a wave of protests
in recent days and normally it’s young people
like Eva, like Gaspar who come here to the
Kossuth square to say "Elég volt," 'It’s
enough'.
What is enough?
"There are certain amounts of things that
we have experienced, the destruction of health
care, the destruction of education, or the
slave-law which is going to make people work
overtime, 400 hours.
The whole society is collapsing on us.
It is suffocating us on all levels."
Unlike past anti-government protests, recent
ones have not ended in Budapest.
They have shifted to the countryside.
We are in Nyiregyhaza, in the Northeast - one
of the poorest regions of Hungary and a stronghold
of Fidesz, the governing party.
I want to ask people about the new labor law
that has triggered the protests.
It allows companies to ask their employees
to work 400 hours overtime every year.
But no one wants to talk on camera, afraid
they may lose their jobs.
I meet Attila Varga, who may not be afraid,
but he's angry.
His job is to drive 500 km through Hungary
every night for a shipping company.
"I start my job every night at eight o'clock
and have to sign that I have finished at 4:30
in the morning.
They make us commit fraud."
In fact, he says he works 12 to 14 hours every
night.
For 400 euros a month.
"The government says there are possibilities.
That’s not true.
There aren’t many jobs.
That’s why you are forced to accept working
overtime."
Attila is concerned that employees will be
exploited even more and he is taking his anger
onto the streets.
Hundreds of others have come to the city center
to protest at what they call "a slave labor
law."
"It will be right here where we kick out the
first brick of the wall that represents the
system of Viktor Orban."
But the organizers, different opposition parties,
call for a peaceful protest.
They don't want clashes with the police.
"They are chanting 'Orban out,' 'We don’t
want your slave law.'
This crowd here is very energized because
all of a sudden the very much fragmented opposition,
the opposition parties are united against
Orban.
And they want to keep this momentum alive."
It’s freezing, way below zero.
The protesters here are determined to fight
in the streets beyond Christmas.
The big question is how many people will support
this new wave of resistance.